turn that great idea into a reality with
Squarespace they make it easier than
ever to launch your passion project do
you want to showcase your work or sell
some products well you can with
Squarespace they have beautiful
templates and the ability to customize
just about anything so you can easily
make a beautiful website yourself if you
get stuck they have 24/7 award-winning
customer support there to help head the
squarespace.com slash Grace for a free
trial and when you're ready to launch
use the offer code grace to save 10% off
your first purchase of a website or
domain not too deep I'm grace Helbig
your host today's a very thrilling very
exciting episode we have Sarah Whittle
with us you may know her from smosh
smosh games smoshgames show network we
talk all about her career trajectory
it's fascinating we also find out that
she was almost formally a contestant on
two different dating shows now currently
married to a beautiful Italian man but
we'll get there enjoy this episode of
not too deep with Sarah Whittle Sarah
Whittle thank you for being here thank
you for having me I'm so glad you asked
me to be here I was I feel honored I'm
very excited because I think you are
wildly fascinating because I'm gonna ask
you I guess the question that I ask a
lot of guests that if people don't know
mm-hmm exactly who they are like what's
your deal what's my deal I guess the
most the easiest way to say Who I am or
give context Who I am in the digital
space I work at Smosh and I've worked at
Smosh for many years on and off mm-hm
and currently I'm the director of
unscripted so I'm basically leader title
I know you lead the creative on Smosh
pit and Smosh games obviously I have
many wonderful people on my team a
talent and cast so but it's interesting
too because you toe the line between
talent and producer I mean you wear both
hats it seems like I do and that was
never my plan so like long story short
like I moved to LA five years ago now
Wow and I came to do the writer/producer
thing I wanted to be like a Tina Fey who
doesn't want to be a Tina Fey she also
became talent not I don't think that was
part of her plan either so i had been
auditioning all over the city and had
been audition i had been auditioning and
kind of like getting my toes wet is that
the phrase you know it sounds weird when
you say it out loud over the place we
have a lot of foot fetish fans so bad we
keep feet score oh you have a you've
checked
yeah because well it's blocked at work
what you see is blocked at work so I
have to wait to go home to see the
monstrosity but like if someone really
dug deep into my Instagram and found the
one time that I dropped a bar of soap on
my foot and it had made a bruise that
went like the whole foot like like a
line of bruise and so then of course I
posted on Instagram in 2011 sure and you
are doing so well Joetta has this nasty
foot pic of like mud and dirt and it
just looks horrible and his Weeki feet
score is higher than mine he's on wiki
fee as well yeah you are too I heard
about I learned about wiki feet years
ago yeah because I my feet are gross and
anytime that I would go to like a carpet
event like red carpet event anyone
wearing heels in like 2010-2011 and I
don't know how to dress myself so I
would go and I'd wear like platform
wedges where my toes are like crawling
over the front of them because it's the
wrong size and people like zoomed in on
that and that's why I found my wiki
feels like a favor this is and I don't
get pedicures like my feet are just yet
occurs either they're like hippy feet
but I haven't checked in in a while I
didn't realize it was still thriving
also I'm just so out of working in an
office that hearing that websites are
blah
like wiki fee is fascinating Tori's
secret is blocked it's like why these
random ass site is there a person that
sits down and has to like add to the
list of block site I think so I think
it's like well yeah that's very very
hilarious
but how you guys like Victoria's Secret
being blocked it seems a little
questionable yeah
anyway we I was auditioning everywhere
so coincidentally at the same time I had
became a host a freelance host at clever
which was also under the defy umbrella
and also working producing behind the
scenes at Smosh so when you okay like to
get to that point yeah you went to
college in Arizona New York in New York
okay
Hofstra University on Long Island yes I
heard of that because I went to Ramapo
College in northern New Jersey yes and
so it's like those are the only I think
they're like kind of similar in size -
yeah it's like a private but it's kind
of big but not super big and people are
always like why are you here all the way
from Wyoming to go to Hofstra yeah
because I was like I want to be in TV
and I was like NYU used to expensive way
to expensive
I saved 10k it year great job not that
much so I went there and then yeah I had
moved to Phoenix for a TV producing job
he went from Wyoming to New York to
Phoenix to go produce television in
Phoenix
yeah what was in Phoenix Phoenix was
this pop culture new show that was kind
of just beginning and it was it's called
the list and it's still on the air now
but it didn't exist when I had joined
the team this is a television show this
is a television show that they were
syndicating to like not top like not the
top markets like New York or LA but it
was in Denver San Diego Phoenix okay and
so all the hot pop culture spots well it
was like you know your pop culture
rundown for moms
e meets the view kinda yeah
so it was like your list of your top
stories of the day and I had helped
create that show and it's still in the
air now it's like in 200 cities now I'm
super proud of that yeah so I did that
with always the thought of maybe going
to LA cuz New York just has no freakin
jobs yeah for TV it's tough yeah so what
was the catalyst that got you to LA did
you just like were you done appeasing
the moms and you're like it's now or
never yeah I was like okay let's go to
LA I've gotten what I got out of Phoenix
I was working that full-time producing
job waitressing and also auditioning on
the side trying to have a real out of
here so full hustle full hustle mode and
then I didn't really move here I used a
friend's address okay told this story
like publicly I would like to hear it as
long as it doesn't like indict you for
like because my oh my la people had to
experience LA they're like they're not
gonna hire you if you don't live in LA
like that's weird but now you get it
hiring in LA and I'm hiring people and
I'm like yeah you're not knowing so I
used my friend's address in Santa Monica
as my address I mean while I was in
Denver with my family because my
grandmother was sick at the time and she
had just passed away so I was like I'm
just didn't take some time meanwhile
also applying for jobs so that maybe one
day right I'll get called I got called
for an interview also was dating a pilot
at the time so I could hop on a plane
know how convenient I thought for a
second you said pirate so yeah I got a
call from Game Show Network game show
named the digital they had a digital
channel there Chen yes GSN oh heck yeah
and they're like can you come for an
interview next week and I was like oh
yeah I'm down the stream so I flew
got a rental car uh-huh with no outbound
date I was just like we'll see what
happened so I did a first interview and
great they're like can you do an
audition tape in a second interview and
this was to be on camera this was like
yeah a hybrid on-camera producer fool
for their YouTube channel that they were
like coming up with so I was like okay
I'll just hang out in LA for like five
days so it's like sleeping on friends
couches and living the dream living the
dream and then did the second interview
and then hopped on a plane went back
home and then like three days later they
were like can you start and I was like
yeah in two weeks we can have later pack
my [ __ ] and just came to LA Wow okay so
then you worked for The Game Show
Network doing producing and hosting of
like they wanted they wanted to do game
shows on YouTube okay so they're like
what are your ideas and I was like I'm
coming from pop culture TV we need Wayne
Brady to host ten more different types
of shows what do you got for him so we
me and a couple of producers there we
would produce like after shows for like
skin wars and then we did a couple
challenge shows and then I had like a
whisper challenge show it was all kind
of rough because it was kind of like my
first venture into digital right did you
have were you like in the YouTube world
like looking at watching things on you
so I was always like obsessed with like
everything you - okay like since like
probably 2010 I would 2011 when it like
really blew up but it's like always
fascinated so even when I worked on the
TV show I was like the you know Internet
Pro right so I was always making like
Internet centric stories gotcha I was
always like a big consumer of digital
content which is helpful for them
because I imagine that people at the
Game Show Network have no clue I mean I
don't want to like you know judge them
they really did they they would bring in
like Trisha Paytas and Jack's films but
then when they brought in like someone
like me
huh they're like who is this and so
views didn't really like keep up gotcha
for them four months later we were told
no one's done like you know good try
good try we gave it a go yeah and so did
you go from game show network to clever
yeah so I went to clever and also
producing for Smosh but it was all
freelance and then eventually you know
if I love to do this perma Lance thing
where you're in like 40 hours but you
don't have like a full-time job sneaky
so I did that for a while and then they
finally offered me a full-time job and I
was basically producing and setting up
everything for Smosh pit okay and
helping with that other people that
don't know what how do you describe
Smosh pit so smart so we all know Smosh
and we have like the sketches every
week's mosh pit is the unscripted side
so we take the talent that are often in
those sketches and we put them in
playing games and write you know
spelling bikini waxes a show I came up
with like a year ago which makes sense
knowing that you have a game show
network background of having to foster
ideas around gamifying thing exactly oh
this all connects Wow I actually felt
like I learned I learned some stuff from
game show network but I really learned a
lot from Joe Bereta Joe was the creative
director of Smosh at the time right when
you came in a lot with him his brain
brain is amazing it works in crazy ways
I don't know how he sleeps because I
feel like his brain is constantly gears
turning ideas chair and he's like also
good at athletics he's also like
charming so funny like it was just like
it's gross gusting so I learned a lot
from him and like spelling bikini came
out of me seeing trivia bidet cuz he
always was like pitching us this idea
you guys are obsessed with genital
hygiene we're like you know people have
personal space and bubbles we want to
get into those crotches in a non-sexual
way
that's a long time for bikini spelling
bikini is we want to get in them
crotches how did you pitch spelling
bikini because if people don't know what
it is you think what it is it's like
that's how I pitch it cuz I was like I
was like what's what's smosh's trivia
bday okay what is it and I was literally
like showering washing my hair and I was
like spelling and so like it was a pitch
meeting and I was just like guys
spelling bikini wax and everyone was
like see really it's the title like all
you need is a solid title that has some
sort of like pun in it or play on words
yeah that really sells it yeah it's
great
everyone was super hesitant I mean most
people were yeah I mean hesitant about
it
yeah I mean you're waxing people's
nether regions in front of other people
and then in front of millions of other
people while doing a spelling bee that's
why it's so hard to put guests like I've
asked you and that's Mary and Hannah I'm
really proud of my boundaries for saying
no I think 2011 grace would have been
like I have to I have to accept
everything that comes my way but that's
one that yeah who knows what 2021
I did it right okay so this is the
reaction wasn't as perverted as I
thought it was gonna be really yeah cuz
that was the thing you were the host of
it for so long and then there was like a
contest if a tweet or something yeah I
did because everyone's like wasn't
Cerrone it my god created the show I'm
the lord of the game but I was like okay
well if we can get like a hundred I
think a hundred thousand likes on the
video I'll be on an episode and so it
happened it happened and how was it for
you you know what I don't like well
you've had a bikini wax before no I've
never what yeah that's also why I was
like I don't think I want my first one
to be
no that's uh now it's public knowledge
no I have it and so my first one I got
right before my wedding okay so it was
like I'm about to leave for three weeks
yeah I don't want to worry about my
armpits my leg that makes total sense to
me I it's an intense experience yeah but
it's not like you're gonna die it's not
anything harder than what women have to
deal with on like let's say a monthly
basis yes so you know everyone can do it
and it's also attended because I got to
see the episode and participate in the
one where the valley folk guys did it
and seeing it in person it's handled
with a lot of respect exactly the girl
that does the the waxing every her name
Rachel Rachel and we also will have a
new waxer when is this coming out but
we're gonna have different waxers okay
well she I feel like you vetted a very
professional
waxer that also is there to have a good
time but is not going to invade anyone's
space in a disrespectful way that's the
thing about any bikini wax is like when
I went to go get my bikini wax for my
wedding the girl was so chill and she
was like telling me about her
ex-boyfriend and I'm like bottomless and
you're just like doing this but you
weren't very comfortable you were in an
intimate in a vulnerable position so she
made herself a little vulnerable to
balanced out the vulnerability yeah okay
so coming up with ideas for stuff like
that in the bit like working with other
people what's it like on a daily basis
that Smosh is everyone just sort of like
is it just one big giant brainstorm
Factory of people just throwing out
ideas in general yeah kinda cuz it's
like we're all creative and we're all
like I would say like everyone that we
have working for Smosh is very talented
and they're all their own personalities
and they're super hilarious yeah so we
take ideas from everyone and anyone and
then you know really it's about
balancing what's realistic what can't we
do what can't we do what makes sense
what's different enough what's not you
know recycled because everything on the
internet has been done yeah it's like
venting the wheel
so it's like how do we apply it to the
Smosh filter as lame as that sounds you
gotta do that because it's like why are
you coming right yeah it's a big
question why are you doing this it's
like do you remember any specific ideas
that were just completely undoable well
it's always like these big big huge
ideas yeah what if we did like a legends
of the Hidden Temple or anything and and
Smosh Summer Games is something that we
do every summer yeah okay I wanted to
talk about this
I've not deep dived into watching it but
it seems like a very grandiose
production yeah it's huge so it started
with Matt Robb and Joe Bereta they
basically were like we had two Smosh
games cast which is video game centric
and then we have this smosh and Smosh
pit cast which is a very personality
sketch driven like how can we make this
all feel like one big family so they're
like we'll divide them up in teams and
have them do competitions in the summer
yeah and the winter we used to do it so
like a big field day yeah a big field
day so that was like it's like always
it's the best memories I've ever had
with Smosh it's so fun so do you guys go
you go like rent a house so it depends
on like a theme so we have to choose
what we don't have to but we choose to
choose and so we've done like the first
one was Beach House we've done summer
camp which was so much fun and we went
to a summer camp place and like rented
out the whole thing and like did
everything there we've done last year we
did a POC elliptic theme so we literally
drove out to the desert for four days so
you guys stay with each other in the
whole time so it basically is like a
summer camp yeah you guys it's kind of
like a company retreat but you're
filming it and making content noticing
like 30 pieces of content in like five
days or whatever it is that's great and
must get insane it is insane and so
that's like a balancing act because
we're like what can we realistically do
and with the time that we have and the
budget and the people and the schedules
like it's a lot it's a lot it's a big
project but we always have like so much
fun with it that's cool are there ideas
for this summer being tossed around
already there are okay but I'll keep
them to your side yeah
I'm very very excited have any
shenanigans gone down that haven't made
it on camera during one of these
escapades mm during a summer games or
winter games yeah I mean not really
actually happens is either filmed or not
or boring we did have like one year at
Winter Games we had a caterer and I
think they wanted to do a whole vegan
menu and and this is maybe one or two
vegans on the entire like casting crew
and every dish had mushrooms every dish
had mush Wow so it was five days of
mushroom and just everyone just ripping
I got to know each other very well I'm
sure yeah so the last night we just like
all went to the grocery store and had
this like massive family like cooking in
the kitchen full like Bacchanalia meat
party yeah exactly that's great it feels
to like it I think you guys do a really
good job at Smosh of you know feeling
authentically like you all genuinely
enjoy each other yeah but it's it is a
big company you know it is like a brand
and you guys are all like working within
it but it genuinely seems like you all
enjoy working together are you trying to
get tea
no no I'm saying it no I do and actually
the team's smaller than it used to be.we
that when we're at defy they would just
hire people they would hire like extra
people but not the necessary so yeah
we're like I think we're 30 or 28 or
something like that which is like a lot
smaller than we used to be at defied if
I used to be like this big kind of more
corporate environment right and so we're
smaller but yeah everyone gets along
it's so much fun that's great I'm
genuinely friends with everyone even
even Matt Rob even Matt Rob yeah as many
questions about Matt Rob we're gonna get
to them in a second we take a quick
break when we get back we have more with
Sarah Whittle I'm not too deep we'll be
right back
[Music]
it's time to turn those dreams into a
reality with Squarespace they make it
easier than ever to launch your passion
project you want to start a new business
showcase some work published some
content sell those products or more
Squarespace is the tool for you they
have beautiful templates created by
world-class designers and the ability to
customize just about anything in a few
clicks so you can easily make a
beautiful website all by yourself they
also have powerful ecommerce
functionality that lets you sell
anything online and analytics that help
you grow your site in real time
everything is optimized for mobile right
out of the box there's nothing to patch
or upgrade ever buying domains is simple
and you'll get the help you need with
Squarespace is 24/7 award-winning
customer support
Squarespace empowers millions of
people's from designers to lawyers
artists to gamers even restaurants and
gyms to turn great ideas into something
real so head to squarespace.com / brace
for a free trial when you're ready to
launch use the offer code grace to save
10% of your first purchase of a website
or domain that squarespace.com / grace
offer code grace give a bunch of stuff
lying around the house that you just
don't use a kids baseball glove that no
longer fits that pair of jeans you only
wore that one time
an old phone hiding in a drawer
somewhere well there's an app you can
use to sell this stuff it's called
mercury mercury is the selling app that
makes it fast and easy to sell almost
anything it couldn't be simpler you just
take a few pics of your stuff you add
description and boom your item is listed
and once it's sold mercury emails you a
shipping label and you just stick it on
and send it off no meetups no hassles
with millions of people using the Macari
app in all 50 states stuff really sells
the app has over 500,000 reviews on the
App Store with an average 4.8 star
rating so why not give it a try don't
let that stuff you don't use go to waste
sell it ship it and get paid with
mercury you can find Macari on the App
Store or armored car e.com m e rc
AR i merc re the selling app
you said you share an office with Matt
Rob mm-hmm that's new yeah I just moved
in we just moved in together have you I
feel like this is like college roommates
like do you guys have like a list of
rules like roommate rules um no it's
more just like me yelling well we're
both yelling at each other a lot it's
like he's definitely like the work
sibling or work husband yeah cuz how
long have you guys known each other now
we've known each other since I started
at Smosh so probably 2015-2016 oh wow
yeah but we never really worked together
we would only work together on summer
games because I was like always wanting
to be a part of creatives right right
when him and Joe would be brainstorming
I'd be like me yeah so yeah and when we
moved to this new iteration of Smosh he
was taking on more I was taking on more
so I've had to like work more together
fun yeah that's exciting
yeah it's also about that no and you
guys like you all hang out after work do
when it blows my mind yeah I'm a very
like solo worker that I'm like when I'm
done I'm like I'm going home and being
by myself for a little bit so kudos yeah
we spend a lot of time together I spend
more time with Matt Robb than my own
husband within Claudio yeah then cloudy
on my husband like it's actually insane
and so when I told him oh hey we're
moving into an office together he was
like oh boy divorce in like five months
Matt matter of and Sarah are gonna fight
let's talk about your Italian husband
yes how do how do who was absolutely
lovely yes how did you guys meet each
other oh well you don't have to tell the
person all i I've told it before and I
told it to Wayne Brady actually funny
enough
god damn it we're getting Wayne Brady
scraps well he's the winner of the mass
singer also something that you and I
yes I want to talk about that too
because you've introduced me to this
whole new world and I just googled it
this morning that the next season
doesn't start till February this is
gonna be a four-hour podcast yeah we
have a lot to talk about okay haven't
even dipped my toe into the reality TV
side of it all
yeah cloudy and I met in 2015
okay it was at a bar cam in person yeah
unheard of these days and we are at a
mutual friend's birthday party okay and
that was back in the day when Sarah was
like single and hot so I like had some
wine and like he had a cute sweater and
some glasses and I kept making eyes at
him and of course he approached me
knowing him now he never would hate me
and so I went up to him and I was like
hi I'm Italian
[Applause]
and then immediately started making out
with him Wow just immediately zero to 60
that was my move I just I love to make
out like that was it was like get a
couple dreams and Sarah see cute boy
list kids did they watch this yeah I got
this I got this and then I was like but
then I was and also the mind frame of
like Sarah you gotta stop making it so
easy for the boys and so I was like take
down my number because he was like I
have to leave and go to work and I was
like really really and so I was like
okay take down my number and he was like
my phone's broken I was like take down
my phone it was completely shattered
take down my number expecting him to do
something cute like go to the bar and
ask for a pen right right I'm gonna
didn't [ __ ] do that [ __ ] because in
his mind the only way you can document
anything is on a phone yeah
then I then I don't remember the rest
and then I left I left and we were both
alone and you were married well and then
so I thirst trapped him so his friend
the next day on Facebook was like thank
you everyone for coming out and I me and
the birthday boy had taken a picture
together and so I my to that status
update with a cute picture and then
friend request came in Wow and social
media game yeah you did it and then when
did you guys get married we got married
a year and a half ago so 2018 September
in Italy in a castle on the Amalfi Coast
in Italy that's so bunker it was so cool
good it's also nuts I mean this is why
you're fascinating because you grew up
like everywhere everywhere where I lived
I'm a military brat my dad's in the Air
Force so I was born in Cheyenne Wyoming
moved to Korea I think a couple times
North Dakota Germany and then back to
Wyoming and I my dad retired I graduated
high school and then I went to New York
Phoenix and then now I'm here in LA Wow
yeah I mean what's so many culture
shocks from Germany to Arizona Germany
to anywhere is like it's so different
did you have a favorite place ceremony
really yeah it's the best thing I've
never been living in Europe is so great
because like the history is beautiful
arm it's beautiful like the cultures
different food is amazing yeah if you
want to go on vacation you can go to
France like we used to go to Luxembourg
for dinner like that [ __ ] is crazy you
just go and it's just there and that's a
sentence it's so rich and fancy but
we're like living on an Air Force Base
would you live in Europe mm-hmm really
yeah so Claudia nice dream is to like
retire and buy like a farmhouse in
Tuscany that would be so pretty
a little business and I have a billion
dogs and well right now you have a
billion cats I have three you've three
cat billion Kathryn I have three that I
show on the internet they don't how many
would you have it if it wasn't illegal
to have good cuz when we had two it's
like cute because really one for you and
for me then when you have three you just
look at them you're like I have three
this is an excessive amount of cash to
but my favorite and it happens so rarely
is to grab all three bundle of like 17
pound cats in my arms I'm sure they love
it they hate every moment of it Bromley
I feed you I clean your [ __ ] torture you
all I want I am your God this is I'm
allowed to do this but you also want a
dog I do I want a dog I don't know what
kind of dog I want many dogs would love
the golden retriever
I would love a pug I wouldn't have Tom
Iranian too named after my mother Kim
because I think if she was a dog she'd
be a Pomerania okay okay what I even
naming a dog mom to me is like the
funniest thing ever
yeah I was gonna mom that's a great idea
especially cuz one of your cats his name
is puppy yes yeah so I feel like you've
already kept them all up in the brain
because Claudio and I we call every cute
animal a puppy okay look at the puppies
in the sky and then we just so happen to
get puppy at that time and his name was
brand well what I guess it's a literary
name out of like some no and I was like
this is not a brain well this sounds
like an off friend like raisin bran
cereal I remember being at like the
adopt like the foster mom and she was
like giving me I was playing with him
and she was like are you gonna keep his
name I was like no I don't think so and
she's like what are you gonna name him
and I was like puppy and she was just
like the weirdest look to me he just
whispered and if I get a dog I'm gonna
name it mom yeah give me your cat
what does Claudio think of all of the
internet stuff because he's not no
involved in that world no he's not at
all which must be refreshing to have a
significant other that's not love it
yeah I love like I'm wanting to step
more away from social media because I
just spend too much time on it well that
was your job at Smosh for a while right
many years yeah that blows my Mike's I
remember going and watching like bring
the funny or something with you and all
the ballet folk and you were like having
to be on your phone to like you know
promote them from the Smosh account I
mean this is so nuts like I get
frustrated checking my own accounts I
don't like to have a job where you have
to be doing yeah working in social media
is actually like it's not you're not
digging ditches or anything like no yeah
if you do become like a social media
manager that's something it really takes
over your life yes I mean when I worked
for a makeup brand you know there are
sales on the weekends your sales during
holidays so you're still working right
and you're kind of expected to because
it's like social media is just as
unending that of content and you need to
get the word out there so yeah I've
enjoyed that Claudio doesn't social
media a lot that's so nice it's nice
yeah it's refreshing yeah I'm like I
need to be less on my phone it's just
I'm on my phone too much yeah what's
your go-to app when you're like when you
pick up your phone Instagram will suck
up my time and yeah I refuse to like
have my own tick-tock so I just like yes
I have it because the Smosh but like I
cannot I haven't done I've made an
account and I opened the app and that's
as far as I got and then I got it's
funny it's overwhelmed but I can't I
can't keep up with just Instagram and
all the apps that I I'm supposed to know
at this point that to introduce a
tick-tock which I'm sure is very user
friendly and I could figure it out but I
just don't want to exactly if you don't
feel compelled to it's better to like
you know focus then to spread yourself
too thin if you're someone that can fire
on all the cylinders like go ahead and
have fun but I'm a big believer in like
just focus on what you like
yeah it's also I couldn't get on the
vine bandwagon
my brain doesn't work in creating
content and those like quick-hit sort of
moment video things yeah like I can't do
that girls get ready for a party like
I'd like I get this and I appreciate the
people that can create this content I
can't I can't do it yeah but that's
really
so Instagram who are your duvan a guilty
pleasure follows on Instagram Oh cuz I'm
a big Britney Spears follow a lot of
like hot girls okay I do like having big
eyelids I have hooded eyes like imagine
that I imagine like liking a bikini one
on and just like feeling competing I
have favorite bikinis I'm like what I
have favorite blankets that I just want
to cover all over me all the time that's
crazy I'm wearing a stained comfy
sweatshirt for the last like four days
straight yeah that's my bikini yes my
home exact tires I like your style cuz
you're really into what is it Dolls kill
yeah I love dolls kill yeah which is
super cool I didn't feel like you have
this kind of like amalgamation of like
you worked in the beauty world and you
like makeup I love makeup you also like
this kind of I don't know even how to
describe it like how would you describe
your style my style is like who knows
what my style is like don't kill is like
if Bratz dolls went to raves yes how I
would describe that but my style it's
like a range okay it's like some people
you know what you're gonna get when you
see their outfit right Clow do you know
what you know what outfit he's gonna get
with Courtney Miller you know like the
kind of outfit for me it's like one day
I'll show up in like this tie-dye
matching hoodie jogger set and then the
next day I'll be wearing like a flannel
dress with heels right and then the next
day I'll be wearing a flower printed
dress keep them guessing it's flexible
it's like whatever I'm in the mood for
how bloated I am feeling that day and
yeah so you have fun I have fun because
I remember my mom when she was like 50
uh-huh
she's Asian so she looks like she's 20
right and she was like all of a sudden
wearing like a lot of Hello Kitty stuff
[Music]
minion shirts and I remember I recall
three years earlier her yelling at me
that I like to look Hello Kitty because
I'm a woman now and I was like mom what
what what what and she was like you know
what I can't wear this stuff forever so
I'm just gonna wear it now cuz I like it
and I was like you know what amen
same so I just like to you know I did a
Marie Kondo thing if it brings me joy
that's where it are there any plans for
the smash pit to extend into the beauty
realm at all we've had brief talks about
it but who knows who knows what the
possibilities are I'm trying to create
my own like content because a lot of
people I think the beauty industry is
very intimidating her beauty vloggers
and instagramers are very intimidating
yes I'm endlessly fascinated by them
because there's a sense of jealousy is
not the right word but a sense of like
appreciation because I know what they're
doing is difficult yes like singing you
and you talk about how amazing it is
that people can be good at singing it's
a superpower which I had but yeah when
people are doing their makeup like I
there's an aspirational side oh yeah
that's like I wish I could like looking
at your eyeshadow today I'm like that
looks beautiful if I tried to do that
it's not that hard yeah I think I could
you got good eyelids girl thank you I
wish all these are fake but you put them
on they look natural thing I think I
would second-guess myself so much before
I left my house that I would end up
wiping it off and just going to like
what my yeah but yeah I'm with you that
like my explore page is always like
beauty gurus and hot girls that I don't
follow but I check out on the explore
page just to look at me like wow they
really pose like that how I do that yeah
yeah or like I call them like the like
fashionable walking instagramers like
they just like we get a dragon like
she'll just wear an outfit and walk and
then get like 4 billion views and you're
saying oh that
I could just walk and be like yeah
making content oh it's great yeah I
started following a bunch of these like
fashion blogger vlogger girls in New
York City and they're all like friends
with each others they'll meet up and do
like cute photo shoots together like
champagne and chanel or something no
it's Rachael Martino who's she's just so
beautiful and like her and her friends
are just like these cute very like
Pinterest esque girls that all I get
together and shoot like very kind of
like um I guess it's like very PG
content like recreate like Gossip Girl
but they'll go to the Upper East Side of
New York and like take photos of it I'm
like I'm fascinated by the fascinated by
it too but I do feel myself sometimes
when I'm like being that a little bit
like I'm a fraud yeah I was brought in
this when I'm not being funny what do I
do but I did see that you started
posting like makeup stuff on your
Instagram I was singing like I was
getting a lot of people being like give
us tutorials because makeup is very
intimidating and like I had to figure it
out because the internet wasn't popping
like it is now and so and all I had was
Walmart and like Seventeen magazine to
look at like they're just showing me the
end how did they get to this exactly
exactly so I was like I'll just make
like not relatable but very like much
easy thanks it's like I want people to
like we're fun eye shadow yes they want
to and it's like very easy to make it
happen so totally I'm like making my own
content to be not accessible
excuse me gross and also make it cheap
because blue tea blimp offers all that
stuff for free and I'll go see how much
it is you're like this is a $70 palette
with four colors this is it only
occasionally have I gotten some free
stuff from makeup brands but it's few
and far between and it's always like
here's a bunch of like highlighters that
I never used like highlighters and then
that's I know I'm like oh wait I'm on
tarts like PR lists now amazing and then
nothing comes in ever again yeah like
how do I get on those lists I feel like
me to scan through then they see my name
and they're like she'll just [ __ ] this
up no you have to look at how much
product there said day-out yeah like
everyone is getting like this launch
like that's such a loss in profits yeah
they probably have to nip and tuck like
how many they're sending out a sister
sending out a thousand that's like
pretty steep very investment yeah but
who knows what's going on in that world
I'm so not knowledgeable about any of it
I feel like every other day someone's
got a makeup line that they're launching
yeah like cool I liked it cuz I did work
for a lie my makeup for a hot second and
I loved working there and it was very
fun to like see a new industry yes I
still worked in social but it was a
completely different business yeah yeah
I also feel like it's just so
competitive there it is
it's insane it seems scary yeah speaking
of things that are competitive the mask
singer you've introduced me to the
wonder that is the masked singer is the
best masked singer
can you send this to the mass singer
producers I want some tickets to the
show I feel like you should be hosting
like the after show of holy oh my god
don't cry don't be like gold I'm putting
that into the universe for you right now
yeah this was a it's so funny because
Wayne Brady won this last season that I
was like showing you close Wayne Brady
is just like spiritually connected to
you all you don't know this since I was
like in high school I was like if I ever
make a show if I ever make like anything
I won't Wayne Brady to be in it because
he's so goddamn talented yeah and he
seems very humble and charming
yeah and he's very real - has he ever
been on Smosh pit no I should reach out
I mean right now he's you should come on
are there you go
collab oh my god I would love it if he
came on try not to laugh or something
like that he would be that he's built
for a show like and that is whose line
exactly except no laughter I respect you
guys doing that that stuff stresses me
out too watching why do you think I've
only been on one episode one it's like
it's so painful and anxiety-inducing to
watch people struggle to try to make
people laugh because like that's my
worst nightmare of all time is someone
not laughing at something I'm
intentionally trying to do to make
myself when I meet people who don't
generally react like to anything they're
famous I hate so emotional
okay mask singer greatest show I'm very
excited to actually watch this season
because you only show me I like the best
parties because we like said that when
we were watching it by you legitimately
want to do it I would love to because I
want to see one whole episode like in
its entirety and see how like it flows
and everything go for everyone that
doesn't know the premise of the show
right the masked singer gets B C D Z
Wireless celebrity yeah it's a range and
they put them in outfits and you never
know who they are and they take on these
personas so it's like an ice-cream cone
or like a panda bear or like a leopard
in Victorian dress some of them are so
intricate the costumes that it's like a
Henson's Muppet it's beautiful but then
they just give up with the backup
dancers yeah leggings from Amazon that
are see-through and like a paper map
they like a party city like morphsuit
yeah so then so so then these masked
singers they come out every week and
they sing and then the judges vote off
who's the worst singer of that episode
then they unmask the masked singer and
then you find out who it is and then
they also have these little packages
right giving hints to who these people
could be right it's just plain old good
ass fun it's AIT's like a murder mystery
because you're trying to guess the whole
time because they're leaving these like
verbal like word clues in like their
descriptions of people yeah and it's
shocking how many of these like you know
z-list celebrities are really good
singers so freaking good and singing
inside of this like cumbersome costume
the whole time yeah let's see what was
on it
yeah it was on it last season and it was
like he was dressed up as like a
Victorian Queen yeah leopard amazing he
would be flirting with Nick Cannon yeah
and he would have
like this weird he would like per all
the time I was like there's no freaking
way this is seal and then and then
klaudia like saw steel like a few weeks
into the masked singer and I was like
tell him he's on the masked singer now
infiltrating your real life would you
ever go on a reality show
yeah oh yeah I mean I know now working
at Smosh is almost like its own reality
it's a reality show but I actually
auditioned for to love reality shows
what yeah it's a pre Claudia this is pre
cow do and then it bled into Claudio
like what we do shows so the shows were
are these like am i violating NDA if
these shows came out that's a you call
and they sue and I give me all of the
information I did I did to love reality
shows one was like a tinder in real life
and then one I was auditioning and then
one was one with like a football player
okay and so I was painfully unemployed
like freelancing fortified I still on
unemployment so I was like let's just
audition for love reality shows why not
I'm bored yeah I have a good story I'm
charismatic I didn't do it so I applied
for to love reality shows and I made it
to the final round
mmm and so they had laces before getting
on the show or usually before it was
like final round of auditions like
castings from yeah and so I had done the
first audition and it was so funny
because I was like in a hotel yeah I was
in a hotel put on like a nice dress you
have to like dress up like a date and
that was like bouncer there like health
things too because they like check if
you're home and then make sure that
you're okay yeah that you're not gonna
have like a full mental breakdown yeah
so then they were like okay we're gonna
do the interview with all the producers
and I'm like okay so I dressed up and
then like the casting lady was like the
girl before you was like so boring so
can you like you're the last one of the
day can you like get up and I'm like
yeah of course and so also thanks for
that and so I came in and like it was
like a room of like 15 people and I
immediately was like high-five
everyone I was ready to touch everyone
in this room and then sat down and had
like an hour interview with that my and
it was really a lot of fun because it
was like being on a late-night show
they're like what do you like about so
much fun and so then the next day I had
the second the second show a final
interview and I was like this is so
weird that they're like in the same week
yeah so I go to another hotel and I wear
the same outfit sketchy and they had me
in the room with a bunch of girls and I
was like this is scary cuz the other one
I was separated right that's when I was
like a cattle call it was like a cattle
call and I was like oh this is scary so
then they put me there like hey Sarah
we're ready for you and it's this woman
I never seen before show Sarah I know
you know what and she was like you're
auditioning for another show I was like
wait this is a woman that worked on this
other show saw their show the second
show and I was like what I did and she
was the producers you were talking to
yesterday or in producing this show -
Wow so they're double dipping your
double dipping Wow
I walked in there like this is
embarrassing because I'm wearing the
same like what did you do last night
like this is why I need a date so I had
done the interview for that and that one
was um for the football player guy and
they were like you're gonna love this
guy he's great he's funny he's
everything you're saying yesterday like
we were thinking about I was like oh my
god and then they had like sent me a
contract to sign and I was like I can't
like legitimately follow through I
didn't do it with your gut instincts but
boy watching The Bachelor I would have
loved a good old chance at that that
would have been so much fun
I just started watching this season cuz
I just watched the last couple seasons
and I got like I had just bothered but
took a break this is the season I'm
actually going back to yeah I just
started with the I guess one of the most
recent episodes I know I was thinking
the same thing of like man I'd love to
just go on the show and [ __ ] some [ __ ]
up yeah
like who would I be would I be like the
crazy girl or what I just try to be the
Bachelorette the next time I just
wouldn't be gonna be Jim Halpert that's
just constantly making asides to any
camera I can find in the room I just
want to be always drinking in the
background never trying to talk to the
bachelor just enjoying that with the
girls oh it's so nuts okay we're gonna
take one last quick break when we get
back there's a billion Twitter questions
for you a billion and they're really
really personal so we're gonna get deep
not so deep when we get back would you
buy a t-shirt for $50 if you knew it
only costs $7 to make I would not and
with ever Lane you never overpay for
quality clothes they make premium
essentials using the finest materials
without traditional markups they want
you to know what you're paying for and
why so they tell you with their real
costs and a radically transparent about
every step in the process from the
materials they use to the ethical
factories they work with no matter your
style preference ever lanes clothes look
better cost less and last longer because
every Lane sells directly to you their
prices are 30 to 50% lower than
traditional retailers essentials like
their cotton crew t-shirts are exactly
what they should be a versatile simple
stylish and made from quality materials
actually as I read this ad I realized
that I'm wearing a never Lane sweatshirt
100% human it says on it very relatable
right now I love their clothes like they
say they're made wonderfully and they
cost a lot less and right now you can
check out our personalized collection at
everland comm slash grace plus you'll
get free shipping on your first order
that's ever Lane comm slash grace every
Lane comm slash grace okay before we get
to these Twitter questions I'm going to
ask you the two questions I ask every
single guest that's on the podcast okay
the first is who alive or dead would you
most want to throw cold spaghetti at
mm-hmm like
an insult it's however your intention
cold spaghetti yes it's just not
satisfying if it's someone I super hate
right I mean so this is entirely a
uniquely your decision yeah
hmm who what I do I I think um what's
his name the chef um the one that once
goes BAM
Oh Emeril Lagasse I feel like you would
just pick it up put in a pot of boiling
water and make a meal but I remember
that I remember watching him growing up
and I was like this is an iconic
celebrity studio audience yeah he would
cook in front of he was a hot [ __ ] okay
the other question is - tell us your
worst pants shooting story work close
call I have too many thank God but you
know I'm always like Tuesday but you can
only tell us in three words or three
small phrases or like a combination of
though so for example mine is college
jogging front lawn that's similar to
Claudio's your soccer for him yeah for
me I would say entire burrito revenge
[Laughter]
revenge on you yes okay well no more
follow-up question okay let's get into
these Twitter questions okay someone
says that someone with two college
degrees hashtag flexed where do you find
your degrees most useful or most applied
as a director of social media
do you find them applied it off because
that's the weird thing I mean yeah I
went to college too but like in this
world it's like you know one way or the
other there's kids at work adults that
work in this industry that have never
gone to my degrees are associates in
communications or in journalism or
something like that and then the second
one is a Bachelor of Arts in television
hmm so I did learn some things there but
I had my first TV job when I was like 16
so I kind of like knew a lot more but I
think College really teaches you how to
like prioritize and make it happen like
that's the realist life experience yeah
part of it is like it there's deadlines
it creates deadlines you learn how to
take notes like those are actually very
valuable and underrated scales that a
lot of people have because you know I've
worked at many different places and
people without self motivation are the
most difficult to work with
yeah I agree that's the one thing I
always say what my college experience
like socially was not the best time but
professionally like was the perfect
safety net transition from like living
with my parents to then being an
independent adult in the real world
because it's what you put into it you'll
get out of it exactly and that I mean I
think is pretty valuable someone to know
can she give a hashtag a wittle advice
on how to be a fashion icon like her oh
I feel like you did talk about this in
your style and your mom seems to be a
big inspiration for the the Freeth like
theory you have around how you want to
dress yourself
yeah well that hashtag is like it's just
a rant I think I've only tweeted it
twice but it's just like whatever I'm
just gonna give advice to like people
yeah if you want to start I would say
you know obviously whatever you're
insecure about you can work around yeah
so for me I don't like tight clothes and
I don't I don't like tight clothes on my
stomach or my chest area yeah so like
find things that work for for what
you're comfortable with and if it's like
not flattering like for me if I know I'm
taking pictures that day I'll wear like
a picture friendly
outfit if I'm not taking pictures I'll
just wear something that I like and it
doesn't matter I'm with you I feel like
also there this evolution of clothes
that are kind of sneaky that are
basically like pajamas they you can wear
and look fashionable yeah and I will say
invest in good shoes and you know that
sounds so dumb when like Clinton Kelly
and Stacy London used to say that one
not to wear whatever pay less all the
way yeah like get good ass shoes you
want have lower back pain and if you
wear them every day you get like ya know
you can get like a 10 cent aware if you
wear them for a year like you know
that's true because like your body might
fluctuate but your feet are always gonna
be about the same size and whenever I
see people walking like like badly you
know like they're in pain yeah and in
there and then I look down there wearing
old navy flip-flops on one side your
self-sabotaging right now a lot of
people have asked the dumbest thing that
you've suggested for a video that didn't
get made I can't remember but I do know
one that was the dumbest suggestion that
did get me oh and it was it was like a
guest that fart and I pitched it to Matt
at the time and I said make a fake butt
and then how the oil diffuser come out
of the butt and then add crazy smelling
essential oils to it and they have to
guess what it is like pizza and sushi I
think I think Steve Zaragoza is in that
video I mean so much terrible idea to me
yeah they're sniffing the essential oil
out of the butt it was like the bet the
butt was so ugly and whoever did that
was like went for it I love that idea I
would do it again yeah I didn't mitt I
didn't know that they made insane
essential oils like that
I haven't delved into that world data
and sushi but I don't I I think they
didn't really smell like the thing okay
yeah well I think that now is the time
to like bring back
around 2:00 okay what's the craziest
thing the smash squad has done on set
that drove you crazy
well well it seems like everyone's a
character but they're all so
professional well they're all a
character I mean sometimes you just go
for it in a video but it's like for me
for me I'm very like empathetic or
sympathetic so yeah used to do the show
called put in my mouth where no grossman
would like try crazy-ass foods and motel
or mystery smoothies and stuff like that
yeah and we had a bucket of shame where
people would barf into a new hole and I
felt so bad making a PA clean that up
though I would always clean it up that's
nice and so that was that's probably
like the thing I hated the most so yeah
that's not my jam no yeah like cleaning
up all the messes is like just not okay
yeah there was a real heyday on YouTube
where it was like eating terrible things
and watching months ago if I wanted to
do an eating thing and I was like I know
I keep saying no to everything I do want
to do sit with you guys but I don't want
to get waxed and I don't want to throw
up in front of you guys yeah I hope you
respect that someone wants to know how
did you come up with your Twitter handle
do you know any Rudy unicorns which is
interesting because then like this yeah
this era where everyone's trying to get
their names
yours is rude unicorn well I was like
should I change it like two years ago
and everyone voted no on my Instagram
but I maybe had a thousand followers
okay let's go back to 2000 let's take a
journey I was like I don't want to do my
actual name because I'm applying for
real jobs [ __ ] secretly I really like
unicorns mm-hmm and I was like what can
I can I hybrid a word you know I was
like rude rude a corns Runa corns and I
was like no just rude unicorns so that
sorta came from and then like I'm not
kidding you right after like unicorns
became way popular and it's just like
oversaturated now and I still get I have
to like tell people don't buy me unicorn
stuff that it's not my jam
committed to leave so I have to commit
to it there's so many videos without
rude unicorns and I can't yeah that's
the that's the the sweet and also like
slightly frustrating thing when you ever
put out there online that you enjoy a
certain thing or that you have an
affinity towards something then it's
like that becomes your identity and what
everyone gets you it constantly
someone's know is there a moment in your
life you wish you could change or have
gone or that it could have gone
differently oh I mean I feel like it's
that dating show casting process as far
as like big life regrets I get I get
very like la you know spiritual about it
that you know what I have been through
guys you brought me into this position
yeah even the shitty things that have
happened to me or that I have done who
brought me to this place and I'm very
happy with the place that I'm in ya know
that I think that sounds boo boo but
it's also true with that being said I
during our wedding vows we set them in
English and Italian and mine were so
long I would have made the Italian
version shorter okay noted who was your
first celebrity crush and is he or she
still your celebrity crush oh well I
didn't crush a lot on people like when
Titanic came out and Backstreet Boys and
NSYNC everyone was like right you know
Leonardo DiCaprio and I wasn't like
crushing super hard so and Backstreet
Boys yeah AJ was like facial hair that's
weird which I'm into is oh so I think
that was just a good omen to like my
Claudio I can see the similarities
between him and AJ
[Laughter]
someone's no what are your what are your
Sarah Whittle bag essentials Oh like
what do you always bring with you
because I feel like every time I see you
you have a different cool bag that
you're carrying yeah I have too many
bags which is great kudos to you
I have such trouble when I transfer
stuff from bag to bag that I contacted
at a time I want to like lactate
shortage every new purse
obviously the wallet but some lip
product okay a lip gloss yes I lip a lip
like stick of some sort
okay a liquid lipstick and black shade
and lactate mm-hmm I feel like that is a
great trifecta yeah how do when we leave
the house that you ever like to I know
you and I both share our lactose my
Lawrence your full intolerant I think I
have a sensitivity I know I'm getting my
gut check lately some it might not even
be that I'm not sure yeah I have my gut
checked last year and they were the guy
was like maybe or have IBS cuz your
stress I'm like no this is like kind of
stomach bacteria my mom so I got that
taken care of and that took care of like
most of the issues but then I was like I
really have a lactose intolerance yeah
and you know because of the convenience
of lactate like why not lactate is great
yeah so now I'm fine in the moment the
next day still very lactate needs
someone like you to be a brand
representative to make it to the list
and I'm like you can't even get on the
lactate this is a thing I want to get
brand deals that are not that are things
that I wouldn't use yeah like I want
like I want a big lots brandy like I
want I want a dollar tree brandy I want
dye so Asian dollar store brand deal
like that's the stuff I want you've
actually use that stuff give me a toilet
paper and squatty potty
and now on two of them a lot of people
are asking who's your like ideal future
guest for spelling bikini wax
hmm oh that's like weird to think about
cuz are you trying to get a good speller
you're trying to get someone that you
want what do you think about people are
good how do you measure it's weird cuz
I'm trying to like for a couple episodes
I went too hard on the words like the
Valley Oak episode I just went to
batshit crazy because that's part of the
fun of this game is because of all of
these modern technologies we have we
don't have to know how to spell things
anymore but then I'm like but then I'm
like I need to go easier yeah with the
words cuz people are just not getting
pressure situation so you're not
breaking that word your pants are down
there's high stakes I don't know I think
it would be like really fun to like take
spelling bikini on like Jimmy Fallon
yeah like I think it'd be really cool to
like do that
yeah I'm just learning from you first oh
my god the rage the rage I would have I
feel like yeah make sure you guys like
trademark that show or something yeah
how do you do that and you just put a
little tiny TM next this is a legal
podcast
what is your favorite smell oh all my
smell my favorite smells are like toxic
to cats so this is a actually legitimate
PSA it might actually save kittens lives
okay
so cats and dogs uh-huh some essential
oils are super toxic to them so if they
like smell them or they get into contact
with them they can like get away or get
a stroke or like serious things could
happen so my favorite smells are
grapefruit citrus lime eucalyptus all
extremely toxic no I don't get that at
my house but those are my favorite
smells they make me relax they make me
feel like my lungs happy place like
filled with air yeah okay last question
if you could take part in any other show
on YouTube which one would it be
hmm well I did trivia bday right because
I know today good for you
you really
the ceiling for females on that show
that's what I'm about is like feminism
quality yeah I always say Real Talk
though that's why I always aim to like
get female guests on spelling bikini
right I'm like I just don't want it to
be like a dude only show yeah like you
girls you can do it you can do it too
also you got the same pay as the men for
doing trivia bday which is zero dollars
so I think what what sure would I like
to be a part of I like weirdly enough I
would like to be a part of like good
mythical morning one day
oh you haven't done that yet in the same
building literally in the same building
but like I don't know I don't know what
they you know they're gonna lean towards
like Courtney and Shane or whatever but
it would be cool to like be a part of
that Oh rhett and Link are like the
super nicest guys in the world it's TV -
they're sweet dream team yeah Sara thank
you for being here this has been so fun
it's so much fun I feel like it went by
so fine I want to keep talking like
before you go oh because well maybe
we'll have to do a part two once you get
your Wayne Brady show going morning
before you go every guess that's on the
podcast gets a personalized fortune
cookie last to them so you feel free to
eat these
we made the fortune we prank people real
hard on this show oh me trying to break
it very soon Ailes and one missing you
know I mean I just got him done but one
popped off in the shower the other day
yeah mercury alright oh this is a long
one for Aquarius horoscope for Aquarius
you will feel things and good things
could or good but you will for sure feel
things about it first and it will lead
to LA unless you already found your love
in which you might find money that might
be your money
dear quick yeah oh my god this is so
relatable right I can see this in my
life I found money in one of my wallets
this morning and I
and you have love I mean the spirit
astrological realm is on your side yes
it's my birthday soon I know I'm so
excited for you um okay where can people
find you and everything you're up to if
they don't know yes so I'm at rude
unicorns on Instagram and Twitter so
there you can stalk me and then if you
haven't for awhile head over to Smosh at
Smosh on YouTube and Instagram and
Twitter and Smosh pit and Smosh games
you'll see my face sir but I not always
but I have a touch and everything hell
yeah thank you again Sarah make sure you
guys go follow her on all the social
media because I want to see more makeup
tutorials please make it relatable we'll
see you guys next time I remember sewed
up not too deep goodbye 2deep 2deep
2deep 2deep not too deep is a production
of grace helbig incorporated producer
Melissa D months edited by Shireen Loni
Eunice post-production sound by Chris
Henry and an extra special thanks to
Flula for the theme music
[Music]